lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
revisar algunas ideas que probablemente
dieron por sentado desde que tenían 3 o
4 años de edad pero espero que puedan
tener otra perspectiva cuando pensemos
en otros tipos de sistemas numéricos en
nuestro sistema numérico tenemos 10
dígitos empecemos a contar si no tengo
nada uso el símbolo 0 si tengo una cosa
uso el símbolo 1 déjenme dibujarlo así
nada luego si tengo una cosa uso el
símbolo 1 si tengo dos cosas uso el
símbolo 2 si tengo tres cosas uso del
símbolo 3 si tengo cuatro cosas uso el
símbolo 4 si tengo cinco cosas cinco
cosas uso este símbolo sí tengo seis
cosas déjenme dibujarlo así si tengo
seis cosas uso este símbolo sí tengo
siete cosas uso este símbolo o no
empieza a ser un poco tedioso pero todo
esto tiene su objetivo si tengo ocho
cosas 8 cosas
este símbolo sí tengo nueve cosas si
tengo nueve cosas uso este símbolo
y si tengo 10 cosas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
que el símbolo podría usar anteriormente
ya use mis 10 dígitos solo tenemos 10
dígitos en el sistema numérico de base
10 así que empecemos a reutilizarlos
introducimos la idea de posiciones
numéricas decimos que tenemos una decena
y 0 unidades
tenemos una decena y 0 unidades
llamamos a esto una decena decimos que
está en la posición de las decenas y
este es literalmente una decena y será
unidades así que es lo que esto indica
pero podríamos no reutilizar los
símbolos podríamos tener más símbolos o
probablemente crear nuevos símbolos en
lugar de estos tener sus propios
símbolos así que en lugar de reutilizar
los otros podríamos tener el símbolo
estrella para el 10 y luego vamos al 11
podríamos tener otro símbolo para el 11
voy al 11 solo para explicarles y dar en
el clavo 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
así que el 11 de nuestro sistema
numérico decimos que es una decena
decimos que es una decena déjenme
escribirlo de esta manera una decena y
luego una unidad así que es una vez 10 +
sé que es un poco extraño verlo escrito
de esta manera pero esta representa este
número de objetos si tenemos un sistema
de base 11 o mejor dicho un sistema de
base 12 podríamos tener símbolos para
eso en lugar de reutilizar todos
nuestros dígitos probablemente un
símbolo podría ser algo chistoso como
una carita feliz podría ser cualquier
cosa
ahora voy a introducir sistemas
numéricos de bases mayores en futuros
vídeos y veremos qué tipos de símbolos
utilizan esos sistemas pero lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es pensar
cómo contaríamos o qué símbolos
utilizaríamos si tenemos menos dígitos y
en este caso particular como contaremos
si tenemos solo dos dígitos solamente 0
y 1 esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer
es pensar como representaremos números
en base 2 nuestro sistema numérico
tradicional es de base 10 y tenemos 10
dígitos del 0 al 9 como contaremos en
base 2 así que si tenemos 0 cosas
probablemente diremos si tengo 0 y si
tengo una cosa también puedo decir hey
tengo una cosa porque tenemos el dígito
0 y el dígito 1 quiero dejar claro esto
los dígitos aquí los dígitos en base 2
son 0 y 1 así que si tengo una cosa
puedo usar el número 1 pero ahora vemos
que si tenemos estas dos cosas aquí
estamos limitados estamos limitados a
estos dos dígitos cómo puedo representar
eso entonces bueno en lugar de tener la
posición de las decenas voy a crear la
posición del 2
sé que suena un poco conflictivo pero se
acostumbran a usarlo así que aquí en
base 10 decimos que tenemos una decena y
0 unidades y en base 2 como lo hacemos
tenemos 120 unidades déjenme de hacerlo
más claro
este de aquí nos está indicando que es
una vez 2 y 0 veces
1 o sean unidades quiero asegurarme de
que entiendan lo que esto significa en
base 10 dejen a escribir un número más
grande en base 10 así que sí escriba el
número 256 en base 10 este de aquí es de
base 10
ya me está indicando está indicando dos
centenas dos centenas
tal vez debo escribir la palabra para
que no haya confusión con los símbolos
dos centenas más cinco decenas mejor
escribiré dos centenas más cinco decenas
dos centenas más cinco decenas más seis
unidades es lo que está aquí
representado
y la manera que lo sé es que si recorro
dos posiciones a la izquierda este es el
lugar de las centenas
este es el lugar de las decenas
y este de las unidades y lo podemos
saber también por el exponente este es
igual a 10 por 10 este de aquí es igual
a 10 por el mismo sólo una vez y este
solo las unidades 0 veces 10 o si
sabemos los exponentes éste es 10 a la
segunda potencia esta es la posición de
10 a la primera potencia y esta es la
posición de 10 a la potencia 0 y si
tenemos otro dígito aquí este sería la
posición de los millares que representa
pies por 10 por 10 vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo en base 2 pero en
lugar de usar 10
vamos a usar 2 así que esta es la
posición de los dos está de aquí es la
posición de los dos y esta es la
posición de las unidades si tenemos más
dígitos déjenme aclarar esto en base 2
en base 2 escribiré un número aquí de
base 2 y recuerden en base 2 solo
podemos usar ceros y unos así que en
base a dos tenemos digamos el número
1010 cuando pensamos de esta mano
si este fuera un número de base 10
tendríamos aquí la posición de las
decenas de las centenas y de los
millares pero ahora está en base 2
quiero ser muy clara estamos usando solo
dos dígitos en base 2 este de aquí sigue
siendo la posición de las unidades
y ahora este va a ser la posición de los
dos recuerden que en base a 10 es la
posición de las decenas ahora es la
posición de los dos revisemos esto las
centenas son 10 por 10 cuando vamos dos
posiciones a la izquierda en base 2
decimos que es la posición de 2 por 2 o
lo que es lo mismo la posición de los
cuatros esta es la posición de los
cuatros y esta de aquí será la posición
de los ochos así que si queremos pensar
en términos de base 2
este es un 8 más 0 4 204 más 12
+ 0 unidades + 0 unidades así que si
queremos representar exactamente el
mismo número en base 10 es un 8 + 12
dejen escribirlo justo aquí en base 10
este sería un 8 más 12 que es justamente
este es un 10 en base de 10
así es como representamos este grupo de
cosas de 10 cosas así es como la
representamos en base 2 y así es como
las representamos en base 10
ahora continuemos aquí solo para
asegurarnos de que estamos entendiendo
si tenemos estos dos objetos tenemos 1 2
y 0 unidades ahora tres objetos serían
uno dos y una unidad
déjenme hacerlo aquí esto sería un dos y
una unidad
esto sería tres objetos en base 2
ahora vamos a este aquí tenemos un 4 0 2
y 0 unidades ahora nos vamos a la
posición de los cuatros porque llegamos
al máximo de las posiciones ocupadas y
tenemos que incrementar una posición más
justo como lo hacemos en base 10 pero
ahora sólo podemos usar los dígitos 0 y
ahora tenemos un 40 20 unidades cuando
agregamos una posición más también
podemos agregar una unidad así que ahora
tenemos un 402 y una unidad y sólo para
tener esto claro estas cosas se
representan así en base 2 esta es la
posición de los cuatros
un 4 y una unidad si queremos convertir
esto a base de 10 miren esto este es un
este es un 402 y una unidad así que si
tenemos un 4 y una unidad representamos
esto como el símbolo 5 en base 10 no
tenemos un símbolo disponible para esto
en base 2 vamos a este
vamos a incrementar uno más así que como
lo representaríamos en base 2 para éste
tenemos definitivamente un 4
luego tenemos 12 y 0 unidades y si
siguen practicando como una diversión
contar en base 2 podrían llegar a
manejar muy bien el sistema numérico de
base 2
ahora vamos a agregar uno más entonces
obtenemos 1 1 1 y vemos que no hay
manera de incrementar uno más a este
número así que tenemos que agregar una
nueva posición tenemos que ir a la
posición de los ochos y tenemos un 8 0 4
0 2 y 0 unidades
este podría parecerles como un 1000 pero
sería 1000 sólo si estuviéramos en base
10 en base 2 éste representa este número
de objetos son 8 objetos en base 2
cuando agregamos uno tendremos todos
estos y tendremos un ocho y luego
tendremos una unidad así que será 1001 y
luego me detendré aquí en lo que
consideramos 10 objetos en base 10
tendremos un 8 y necesitamos un 2
así que 04 12 y 0 unidades
y esto que tenemos aquí es un 10 en base
2 y esto es un 10 en base 10 espero que
no estén muy confundidos